[Music]
this town has told stories horrible
stories but they don't realize I have
scary stories
tell me a story why are people so
obsessed with scary stories like what is
it about scary stories that brings it
together what gives it that feeling I
don't know it's like what you were
saying earlier today that it's uh there
is a community experience in horror and
in being scared that it's so wonderful
to experience the balance between being
scared and actually almost needing to
laugh afterwards just to release the
tension of the scare and I think that's
a lot of the the fun of telling each
other scary stories which is we're just
kind of doing that telling other people
scary stories I think that they the in
Mexico when we discuss a movie and we
call it
we don't say melodrama we say i crying
movie we don't say horror we say a scary
movie
we don't say comedy we say a funny one
you know and it's because I think those
three our emotions that we loved
recognizing on each other and when you
get together in the theater and
everybody is scared at the same moment
you have this almost like a concert
experience where you all react at the
same time and it's beautiful is very
connecting it's very empathic and we
love I mean we live lives in which we
avoid emotion we seek comfort our lives
are uneventful and by nature as animals
as narrative animals we need the scare
we need the laughter we need the cry we
need the love experience so you get it
through narrative and we complete it
[Music]
some people believe if we repeat stories
often enough
they become real they make us who we are
that can be scary
eat it Harold at the end of the book
Alvin wrote these are stories that are
scary but are meant to make you laugh I
don't know if you guys remember that yes
will there be horror or scary stories in
this movie don't make as much well I
think that the beauty from the there are
two types of horror the one that is very
scary and dark and scaring and then
there is a fun horror where you giggle
in anticipation and you laugh and
recognition but you're you're still
scared that type of element is there
yeah I think I think there is a lot of
humor in the film actually and also in
there is a balance between humor and
scares also in the sappy sequences that
I think it's joyful to be scared in this
movie I think some kids went missing so
they boarded it up
okay
I saw it we go now toward the chicken
one of my favorite things you guys also
mentioned yesterday at the event is that
you picked specific stories for a
specific character which story embody
which character for example Ruth the red
spot was perfect for her because she's
obsessed with perfection you guys had to
pick a scary story that embodied you
what would it be and why there's a story
in the book that I loved that I wanted
to put in that embodies what I believe
is her job it's called the window and
it's about a guy in that is laying on a
bed convalescent and there's another guy
next to him and one of them has a view
to the window the other one doesn't and
he tells him everything that is outside
and and the other one grows ambience and
he doesn't have that view and if this
character is dead the other one gets to
the bed and he realizes there was a
brick wall and that everything came from
the imagination of the guy that that he
hated you know and I feel that that's
the role of a storyteller in our society
we are looking at a brick wall and we
have to invent all these things it's
roughly about five or six you know and
some of them are reference some of them
are combined like the jangly man which
is a creature we created is a
combination of two there is about five
or six top of the charts the ones that
everybody wants there will be some
people that say oh I want this other one
and one the Mexican pet or I want this
and that I mean I guarantee you most of
the it was the people wander in the
you don't read the book
the book reads you
no it's not an ontology at all it's a
very cohesive story I'll leave it at the
beginning in Al and it's basically a
group of kids in the last summer of
their childhood about to get the real
world university war adulthood
discovering what is stories do to their
lives and finding each other in the
middle of a horrifying adventure in
which they tried to decipher the mystery
of a girl in the eighteen hundred's that
wrote a book that writes itself and
finds the scariest things you can
experience each and every one that takes
the book experiences a horrible story
and the characters live through them
together and why it was important to set
it in a time where we could have
recognizable reality in which a time of
turmoil that is relevant to the theme of
stories a time of great lies and a great
story is being told to the entire
country the last one of the last years
of innocence also for America you know
and and to have the kids in a world
where verbal and written story is
important and it's not disposable you
don't have it on your iPhone he's not
changing every five minutes so it has a
weight and they don't have Google to
decipher the mystery I think they cannot
dial nine-one-one
in the street corner and and basically
in terms of world experience
seventeen-year-old and 68 is a 12 year
old now so it allowed us to to set it in
a time that was relevant to the
storytelling I remember you mentioned
yesterday but fell in love with the
screenplay
so after you read the screenplay did you
go back and read the book oh yeah of
course yeah no there were great little
stories of
that have just tension and in a way a
very playful attitude I mean there is a
lot of them actually end with some the
sentence and then you turn to your
friend and you say boo and we actually
do that in a movie as a gag to live up
to that that thing and I think that
that's part of the playfulness of the
books and also part of the playfulness
of the film ah yeah yeah I mean the way
Andra planned the set pieces they play
beautifully only no no dialogue just
sound and images and camera movement and
suspense and they build a beautiful
setup and it has a great punch line you
know and then they continue is really I
think his set pieces are fantastic in
this morning
the jingling man is coming
what makes these stories so scary like
what element doesn't have to have
simplicity I think I think that the best
thing and this stories is simplicity
that you recognize what is about to
happen and then it happens and you're
still earth scared what was your
favorite creature to create I mean I
said maybe we have the same one but I
think the pale lady is the most the one
that feels just so unique to me because
she is both benign she appears benign
she has a kind of Mona Lisa smile but
it's crazy yeah and then these eyes
there yeah and she's just kind of
relentless at the same time as she's so
there is a there is a fun balance
between several elements in her entire
being that I think is yes and that's the
same for me what we wanted was to try to
emulate with the creatures the black and
white feeling of the illustrations in
the book so we knew we wanted them
drained of color you know so we tried to
make them parchment yellow sort of
nicotine yellow and white so we went for
the the saturation in the bridges all of
them you know and obviously you light
them differently for example the corpse
in the story the big toe is lid with a
cyan light so it looks blue greenish but
the length of the sculpture and the
painting is very pale parchment well I
think that in many ways is of a piece
with many of them I mean the orphanage
mama Devil's Backbone
they have a young characters in danger
but what is beautiful about this is that
it has a playfulness that none of the
other movies have like there's a much
more there's a deeper darkness and
things like the orphanage or mama
this is as a very gentle spirit is is it
has a really terrifying moments really
hardcore
but it has a fun factor that I think is
Andres doing and the screenplay is going
and the spirit of the book when you read
Stephen King is never going to be in the
young adult section but you can find
really scary stories in the young adult
section this is a young adult section
type of moving